POLICING IN AMERICA.
>> BY THE WAY, PLEASE SIT DOWN.
I'M SORRY.
PLEASE SIT DOWNMENT I KEEP
FORGETTING.
THANK YOU.
LOOK, WHEN I RAN FOR PRESIDENT,
I SAID I LOOKED AT THE WORLD THE
WAY I LOOKED AT A GROWN-UP IN
SCRANTON, AND THAT WASN'T
HYPERBOLE, I MEANT THAT.
WHAT FAMILIES WANTED IN SCRANTON
WHEN I WAS GROWING UP WITH MY
MOM AND DAD AND GRANDPOP WAS AS
BASIC AS IT IS TODAY, A DECENT
JOB, THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE
TREATED WITH DIGNITY, EVERYONE,
MY DAD WOULD SAY, EVERYBODY.
EVERYBODY'S ENTITLED TO BE
TREATED WITH DIGNITY, TO SIMPLE
DIGNITY.
THE FACT IS THAT THEY WANT TO BE
ABLE TO GO TO GOOD SCHOOLS, STAY
IN SAFE NEIGHBORHOODS, A DECENT
PLACE TO LIVE, AND JUST A FAIR
SHOT, JUST A FAIR SHOT FOR THEIR
KIDS.
YOU KNOW, A PEACE OF MIND
KNOWING YOUR KIDS CAN GO TO
SCHOOL OR A PLAYGROUND OR MOVIES
OR A HIGH SCHOOL GAME AND COME
HOME SAFELY AND NOT HAVE TO
THINK ABOUT IT.
BUT FOR TOO LONG, TOO MANY
FAMILIES HAVEN'T HAD THAT PEACE
OF MIND.
THEY WATCH THE NEWS AND THEY SEE
KIDS BEING GUNNED DOWN IN
SCHOOLS AND ON THE STREETS.
ALMOST EVERY SINGLE NIGHT YOU
TURN THE NEWS ON, THAT'S WHAT
YOU SEE.
THEY SEE THEIR NEIGHBORS LOSE
THEIR LOVED ONES TO DRUGS LIKE
FENTANYL, WHICH IS A FLAT
KILLER.
THEY SEE HATE AND ANGER AND
VIOLENCE, JUST WALKING THE
STREETS OF AMERICA.
AND THEY JUST WANT TO FEEL SAFE
AGAIN.
THEY WANT TO FEEL A SENSE OF
SECURITY.
AND THAT'S WHAT MY CRIME PLAN IS
ALL ABOUT.
YOU KNOW, I CALL IT THE SAFER
AMERICA PLAN, AND BOTH MEMBERS
OF CONGRESS VOTED FOR IT.
IT'S BASED ON A SIMPLE NOTION.
WHEN IT COMES TO PUBLIC SAFETY
IN THIS NATION, THE ANSWER IS
NOT DEFUND THE POLICE, IT'S FUND
THE POLICE.
[ CHEERING AND APPLAUSE ]
FUND THE POLICE, AND GIVE
THEM -- WE EXPECT THEM TO DO
EVERYTHING.
WE EXPECT THEM TO PROTECT US, TO
BE PSYCHOLOGISTS, TO BE
SOCIOLOGISTS, I MEAN, WE EXPECT
YOU TO DO EVERYTHING.
I'M NOT JOKING.
EVERYTHING.
YOU REALIZE MORE POLICE OFFICERS
ARE KILLED DEALING WITH DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE THAN ANYTHING ELSE?
DO YOU REALIZE THAT?
THE POINT IS WE ASK SO MUCH OF
YOU, SO MUCH OF YOU.
I'VE NOT MET A COP WHO LIKES A
BAD COP.
THERE'S BAD IN EVERYTHING.
THERE'S LOUSY SENATORS, THERE'S
LOUSY PRESIDENTS, THERE'S LOUSY
DOCTORS, THERE'S LOUSY LAWYERS,
NO, I'M SERIOUS.
BUT I DON'T KNOW ANY POLICE
OFFICER THAT FEELS GOOD ABOUT
THE FACT THAT THERE MAY BE A
LOUSY COP.
I'M TIRED OF NOT GIVING THE KIND
OF HELP THEY NEED.
FOLKS, LOOK, WE'RE IN A
SITUATION IN THIS COUNTRY WHERE
WE HAVE TO GIVE THEM ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES THEY NEED TO GET THEIR
JOB DONE.
MATT GETS IT.
MATT CARTRIGHT, THIS IS NOT
HYPERBOLE.
MATT'S THE CHAIR OF THE POWERFUL
SUBCOMMITTEE THAT CONTROLS THE
FUNDING FOR PUBLIC SAFETY.
HE KNOWS WHAT IT MEANS INVESTING
IN AN EFFECTIVE AND ACCOUNTABLE
COMMUNITY POLICING THAT BUILDS
PUBLIC TRUST AND STRENGTHENS
PUBLIC SAFETY.
I'M OLD ENOUGH TO REMEMBER WHEN
COPS USED TO WALK THE BEAT IN
WILMINGTON AND SCRANTON BECAUSE
THEY KNEW EVERYBODY.
THEY KNEW IF SOMEONE WAS IN
TROUBLE, THEY KNEW WHOSE HOUSE
TO GO KNOCK ON THE DOOR, AND
SAY, MOM, YOUR SON JUST DID.
I'M NOT BEING FACETIOUS.
THEY KNEW THE NEIGHBORHOODS.
AS PART OF THE AMERICAN RESCUE
PLAN, I SIGNED INTO LAW, WHICH
THEY VOTED FOR, WE SET ASIDE 350
BILLION WITH A B, BILLION
DOLLARS, FOR STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ALL ACROSS AMERICA.
AND URGE THEM TO USE IT LIKE
YOUR GOVERNOR DID TO MAKE
COMMUNITIES SAFER.
HERE IN PENNSYLVANIA GOVERNOR
WOLFE WAS USING $250 MILLION OF
THAT MONEY TO REDUCE CRIME AND
VIOLENCE ACROSS THIS STATE [
APPLAUSE ] AND MAYOR BROWN JUST
DESCRIBED HOW IT'S HELPING FUND
COMMUNITY POLICING HERE IN
WILKESBURY, BUT GUESS WHAT,
EVERY SINGLE REPUBLICAN MEMBER
OF CONGRESS, EVERY SINGLE ONE IN
THIS STATE, EVERY SINGLE ONE
VOTED AGAINST THE SUPPORT FOR
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
THEY TALK ABOUT HOW MUCH THEY
LOVE IT.
THEY VOTED AGAINST THE FUNDING.
FLAT OUT.
EVERY REPUBLICAN IN THE HOUSE.
EVERY REPUBLICAN IN THE SENATE.
EVERY SINGLE ONE.
I KNOW WE EXPECT SO MUCH FROM
OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS, SO
WE NEED TO SUPPORT THEM.
THAT'S WHY MY CRIME PLAN TO HELP
COMMUNITIES RECRUIT, HIRE, AND
TRAIN NATIONWIDE MORE THAN
100,000 ADDITIONAL OFFICERS,
ACCOUNTABLE OFFICERS FOR
COMMUNITY POLICING.
AND I MEAN IT.
[ APPLAUSE ] FOLKS, WHEN IT
COMES TO FIGHTING CRIME, WE KNOW
IT WORKS.
OFFICERS ON THE STREET WHO KNOW
THE NEIGHBORHOOD, NOT A JOKE,
WHO KNOW THE NEIGHBORHOOD, WHO
KNOW THE FAMILIES THEY'RE
PROTECTING, WHO GET THE TRAINING
THEY NEED TO BE ABLE TO DO THEIR
JOBS WELL, WHO WORK TO EARN THE
COMMUNITY'S TRUST, AND AS WE
HIRE MORE POLICE OFFICERS, THERE
SHOULD BE MORE TRAINING, MORE
HELP AND MORE ACCOUNTABILITY.
WITHOUT PUBLIC TRUST LAW
ENFORCEMENT CAN'T DO ITS JOB
SERVING AND PROTECTING ALL THE
COMMUNITIES.
IF I CAN JUST INTERJECT FOR A
MOMENT, MY DECEASED SON BEAU, HE
WAS THE ATTORNEY GENERAL OF THE
STATE OF DELAWARE, AND WHAT HE
USED TO DO IS GO DOWN ON THE
EAST SIDE, CALLED THE BUCKET,
HIGHEST CRIME RATE IN THE
COUNTRY.
IT WAS A PLACE WHERE I WAS THE
ONLY WHITE GUY THAT WORKED AS A
LIFE GUARD DOWN IN THAT AREA ON
THE EAST SIDE.
AND YOU COULD ALWAYS TELL WHERE
THE BEST BASKETBALL IN THE STATE
IS OR THE BEST BASKETBALL IN THE
CITY IS, IT'S WHERE EVERYBODY
SHOWS UP.
HE WOULD GO DOWN AND HANG OUT
AND SIT ON A BENCH WITH MY
GRANDSON WHO'S NOW 17 YEARS OLD,
AND THE POLICE USED TO BE IN THE
CAR, LOCAL CITY POLICE, AND
HIELD WALK UP AND BANG ON THE
WINDOW, SAY GET OUT OF THE CAR,
MEET THESE PEOPLE, LET THEM SEE
YOU, LET THEM KNOW WHO YOU ARE.
WELL, THE TRUTH WAS, REMEMBER
WHAT HAPPENED TO COMMUNITY
POLICING, WE WENT FROM HAVING
ENOUGH COPS ON THE STREET TO
CITIES DOING WELL AND THEN
DECIDING THEY DON'T NEED MORE
POLICE OFFICERS.
SO THEY REDUCED THE POLICE
FORCES SO YOU DIDN'T HAVE TWO
COPS IN EVERY VEHICLE.
YOU HAD ONE COP IN EVERY
VEHICLE, AND I DON'T BLAME ONE
COP FOR NOT GETTING OUT IN SOME
CERTAIN NEIGHBORHOODS, NOT
GETTING OUT OF THE CAR.
AND WHAT HAPPENS IS IT USED TO
BE, I CAN REMEMBER THAT WHEN MY
SON WAS THE ATTORNEY GENERAL, HE
WOULD GO AROUND IN THE TOUGHER
NEIGHBORHOODS AND HE WOULD
ENSURE THAT EVERY SINGLE COP
GAVE HIS CELL PHONE NUMBER TO
THE LOCAL LIQUOR STORE OWNER,
THE LOCAL CHURCH, THE LOCAL
GROCERY STORE, THE LOCAL
HAMBURGER JOINT, SO IF THERE'S A
PROBLEM, THEY GET ON THE PHONE
AND CALL.
WHAT DO PEOPLE NOT WANT TO DO,
THEY DON'T WANT TO BE IDENTIFIED
AS TURNING SO AND SO IN.
I REMEMBER GOING ON THE EAST
SIDE IN WILMINGTON, AND ONE OF
THOSE OLD VICTORIAN THREE-STORY
APARTMENT BUILDINGS, AND GOING
UP TO SEE A WOMAN WHOSE NAME,
SHE'S PASSED AWAY, I WON'T
MENTION HER NAME NOW, AND STAND
IN THAT ROTUNDA, THAT PART THAT
STUCK OUT AROUND THE BUILDING,
AND SHE SAID, JOEY, I KNOW -- I
KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON.
THEY ALL PLAN IT DOWNSTAIRS.
I CAN HEAR THEM.
BUT
THE GANGS.
SO I GOT A PHONE NUMBER FOR THE
LOCAL COPS.
SHE CALLED.
THEY PROMISED NOT TO IDENTIFY
HER BECAUSE THEY KNEW THERE
WOULD BE RETRIBUTION, AND THE
CRIME RATE STARTED TO DROP, FOR
REAL, NOT A JOKE.
YOU GOTTA KNOW PEOPLE.
YOU GOTTA KNOW AND BE ABLE TO
TRUST THE POLICE.
THE POLICE HAVE TO BE ABLE TO
TRUST THE COMMUNITY.
BUT WE SLIPPED AWAY FROM THAT.
WE HAVE A HELL OF A LOT FEWER
COPS TODAY THAN WE DID WHEN I
WROTE THAT INITIAL CRIME BILL.
BUT NOW WE HAVE TO GET BACK TO
IT.
BY THE WAY, I'M NOT MAKING A
CASE THERE AREN'T BAD COPS.
THERE ARE SOME REALLY LOUSY
COPS.
THERE'S SOME REALLY LOUSY
DOCTORS, REALLY LOUSY LAWYERS.
I MEAN IT.
BUT HERE'S THE POINT.
AS WE HAVE SEEN TOO OFTEN,
PUBLIC TRUST IS FRAYED AND
BROKEN, AND IT UNDERMINES PUBLIC
SAFETY WHEN IT GETS FRAYED.
IT LITERALLY UNDERMINES SAFETY.
FAMILIES ACROSS THE COUNTRY HAVE
TO ASK, WHY IN THIS NATION, FOR
EXAMPLE, SO MANY BLACK AMERICANS
WAKE UP KNOWING THEY COULD LOSE
THEIR LIFE JUST BY LIVING THEIR
LIVES.
COME FROM NEIGHBORHOODS LIKE I
COME FROM DOWN IN DELAWARE, IF
YOU HAVE A 16 OR 17-YEAR-OLD SON
AND THEY GET THEIR DRIVER'S
LICENSE, YOU SIT DOWN AND SAY IF
YOU GET STOPPED, PUT YOUR HANDS
ON THE WHEEL, DON'T DO ANYTHING.
I'M BEING SERIOUS.
BUT HERE'S THE POINT.
SIMPLY JOGGING, SLEEPING IN
THEIR HOMES, YOU KNOW, THEY MADE
HEADLINES OR NOT, A LOT OF LOST
SOULS.
INCREASED TRUST MAKES POLICING
MORE EFFECTIVE.
AND IT STRENGTHENS PUBLIC
SAFETY.
AND THE COMMUNITIES, BY THE WAY,
THAT WANT THE POLICE MORE THAN
ANY OTHER COMMUNITY ARE THE
TOUGH, POOR COMMUNITIES.
BLACK, WHITE, IMMIGRANTS, THEY
NEED THE HELP.
THEY WANT THE HELP.
IT'S NOT THAT THEY DON'T WANT
IT.
THEY WANT THE HELP.
WITHOUT THAT, VICTIMS DON'T CALL
FOR HELP.
WITNESSES DON'T STEP FORWARD.
CRIMES GO UNSOLVED.
JUSTICE ISN'T SERVED.
I TOOK EXECUTIVE ACTION, WHICH
I'M ALLOWED TO DO AS PRESIDENT,
I ALWAYS ADMIRED GOVERNORS CAN
TAKE EXECUTIVE ACTION, BUT ALL
KIDDING ASIDE, TO MAKE SOME OF
THESE REFORMS FOR FEDERAL
OFFICERS, I COULDN'T DO IT FOR
STATE OFFICERS.
ONE, NO FEDERAL OFFICER IS
ALLOWED TO USE A CHOKE HOLD.
NO FEDERAL OFFICER CAN DO
RESTRICTED NO-KNOCK WARRANTS.
WE CREATED A NATIONAL DATABASE
FOR OFFICERS WHO HAVE MISBEHAVED
SO THEY CAN'T HIDE.
MY PLAN WILL MAKE SURE STATE AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ADOPT THESE
SAME REFORMS.
MY PLAN DOES SOMETHING ELSE
REALLY IMPORTANT.
IT ADDRESSES THE OPIOID
EPIDEMIC.
YOU KNOW HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE
DYING OF OPIOID OVERDOSES NOW,
AND BY THE WAY, LACED WITH
FENTANYL.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL CAN TELL
YOU MORE ABOUT THAT.
HE'S BEEN SUCH A STRONG LEADER
ON THIS, BUT WE'RE GOING TO
IMPOSE TOUGHER PENALTIES FOR
DEADLY FENTANYL TRAFFICKING
THAT'S POISONING COMMUNITIES
ACROSS THIS COUNTRY.
THIS IS A KEY PART OF THE UNITY
AGENDA I'M ANNOUNCING, THAT I
ANNOUNCED IN MY STATE OF THE
UNION ADDRESS.
WE CAN DO THIS.
WE HAVE TO DO THIS.
WE'LL MAKE AMERICA SAFER.
MY PLAN ALSO TAKES COMMON SENSE
ACTION TO REDUCE GUN VIOLENCE
AND VIOLENCE OVERALL.
IT BUILDS ON THE PROGRESS WE
MADE THIS SUMMER WHEN I SIGNED
INTO LAW THE BIPARTISAN SAFER
COMMUNITIES ACT, THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT GUN SAFETY LAW WE
PASSED IN 30 YEARS.
TOOK 30 YEARS.
[ APPLAUSE ]
AND WE BEAT THE NRA.
WE TOOK THEM ON AND WE BEAT THE
NRA STRAIGHT UP.
YOU HAVE NO IDEA HOW
INTIMIDATING THEY ARE TO ELECTED
OFFICIALS.
THE NRA WAS AGAINST IT, WHICH
MEANS A VAST MAJORITY, THE VAST
MAJORITY OF REPUBLICANS IN
CONGRESS COULDN'T EVEN STAND UP
AND VOTE FOR IT.
BECAUSE THEY'RE AFRAID OF THE
NRA.
IT'S NOT UNUSUAL.
DEMOCRATS, REPUBLICAN SENATORS,
THEY GET AFRAID OF CERTAIN
INTEREST GROUPS.
THEY VOTED AGAINST IT.
LAW ENFORCEMENT SUPPORTED IT.
FAITH LEADERS AND TEACHERS
SUPPORTED IT.
VICTIMS OF GUN VIOLENCE AND
THEIR FAMILIES SUPPORTED IT.
YOUNG PEOPLE IN THIS COUNTRY
LIKE THE STUDENTS OF THE GREAT
UNIVERSITY SUPPORT IT.
AND THE NRA AND THE VAST
MAJORITY OF CONGRESSIONAL
REPUBLICANS VOTED AGAINST IT,
SAVING LIVES AND KEEPING AMERICA
SAFE, BUT GUESS WHAT, WE TOOK ON
THE NRA AND WE'RE GOING TO TAKE
THEM ON AGAIN, AND WE WON.
AND WE WILL WIN AGAIN.
WE'RE NOT STOPPING HERE.
I'M DETERMINED TO BAN ASSAULT
WEAPONS IN THIS COUNTRY.
DETERMINED.
I DID IT ONCE BEFORE.
AND I'LL DO IT AGAIN.
FOR MANY OF YOU AT HOME, I WANT
TO BE CLEAR, IT'S NOT ABOUT
TAKING AWAY ANYBODY'S GUNS.
IN FACT, WE SHOULD BE TREATING
RESPONSIBLE GUN OWNERS AS
EXAMPLES HOW EVERY GUN OWNER
SHOULD BEHAVE.
I HAVE TWO SHOTGUNS AT HOME.
I'M NOT OPPOSED TO GUNS.
BUT I SUPPORT THE SECOND
AMENDMENT.
I SUPPORT THE SECOND AMENDMENT,
BUT THE SECOND AMENDMENT, THAT'S
ONE OF THE MOST CONSERVATIVE
JUSTICES IN HISTORY, JUSTICE
SCALIA ONCE WROTE, QUOTE, LIKE
MOST RIGHTS, THE RIGHTS GRANTED
BY THE SECOND AMENDMENT ARE NOT
UNLIMITED.
THEY'RE NOT UNLIMITED.
RIGHT NOW, YOU CAN'T GO OUT AND
BUY AN AUTOMATIC WEAPON.
YOU CAN'T GO OUT AND BUY A
CANNON.
AND FOR THOSE BRAVE RIGHT-WING
AMERICANS WHO SAY IT'S ALL ABOUT
KEEPING AMERICANS INDEPENDENT
AND SAFE, IF YOU WANT TO FIGHT
AGAINST A COUNTRY, YOU NEED AN
F-15, SOMETHING A LITTLE MORE
THAN A GUN.
I'M NOT JOKING.
THINK ABOUT THIS.
THINK ABOUT THE RATIONALE WE
USE, THAT'S USED TO PROVIDE
THIS.
AND WHO ARE THEY SHOOTING AT?
SHOOTING AT THESE GUYS BEHIND
ME.
FOLKS, LOOK.
I WENT TO EVERY MAJOR SCHOOL
SHOOTING IN THE COUNTRY SINCE I
WAS A CHAIRMAN OF THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE ALL THE WAY THROUGH AS
VICE PRESIDENT AND PRESIDENT.
OVER 48,000 PEOPLE DIED FROM
GUNSHOT WOUNDS IN 2021.
IN THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
OVER 26,000 BY SUICIDE.
WHEN GUNS ARE THE NUMBER ONE
KILLER, LISTEN TO THIS, WHEN
GUNS ARE THE NUMBER ONE KILLER
OF CHILDREN IN AMERICA, OF
CHILDREN, NUMBER ONE, MORE
CHILDREN DIE FROM GUNS THAN
ACTIVE DUTY POLICE AND ACTIVE
DUTY MILITARY PERSONNEL
COMBINED.
HEAR THAT AGAIN.
MORE CHILDREN IN AMERICA DIE
FROM GUNS THAN ACTIVE DUTY
POLICE AND ACTIVE DUTY MILITARY
IN THE UNITED STATES COMBINED.
WE HAVE TO ACT.
WE HAVE TO ACT FOR THOSE
FAMILIES IN BUFFALO, UVALDE,
NEWTOWN, EL PASO, PARKLAND,
CHARLESTON, LAS VEGAS, ORLANDO.
I HAVE BEEN TO EVERY ONE OF
THOSE SITES.
SIT DOWN WITH THOSE PARENTS.
I SPENT FOUR HOURS LAST TIME,
MET WITH EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THE
PARENTS AND FAMILIES THAT LOST
SOMEONE.
SEE THE LOOKS ON THEIR FACES.
THINK ABOUT IT.
THINK ABOUT THE DEVASTATION
THAT'S OCCURRED.
WE HAVE TO ACT FOR ALL THOSE
KIDS GUNNED DOWN ON OUR STREETS
EVERY SINGLE DAY THAT NEVER MAKE
THE NEWS.
THERE'S A MASS SHOOTING EVERY
DAY IN THIS COUNTRY IN THE
STREETS OF AMERICA.
EVERY SINGLE DAY.
YOU HAVE TO ASK, YOU HAVE TO ACT
SO OUR KIDS CAN LEARN TO READ IN
SCHOOL INSTEAD OF LEARNING TO
DUCK AND COVER.
LITERALLY.
SCHOOLS ALL ACROSS AMERICA, KIDS
ARE SHOWING UP.
[ APPLAUSE ]
THE PSYCHOLOGICAL DAMAGE DONE TO
OUR KIDS, NOT JUST COVID, BUT
HOW IT'S IMPACTED US, AND ON TOP
OF THAT, THE CHILD GOING TO
SCHOOL, CHILDREN SEE THIS ON
TELEVISION.
YOU KNOW, WE'RE LIVING IN A
COUNTRY AWASH WITH WEAPONS OF
WAR.
WEAPONS THAT WEREN'T DESIGNED TO
HUNT, WERE DESIGNED TO TAKE ON
AN ENEMY.
THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE DESIGNED TO
DO.
FOR GOD'S SAKE, WHAT'S THE
RATIONALE FOR THESE WEAPONS
OUTSIDE OF A WAR ZONE?
THEY INFLICT SEVERE DAMAGE.
WHEN I WAS RECENTLY IN UVALDE, I
ALMOST HESITATE TO SAY IT
BECAUSE SOME OF THE KIDS ARE
THERE.
YOU KNOW WHAT SOME OF THE
PARENTS HAD TO DO?
SUPPLY DNA, SUPPLY DNA BECAUSE
THE AR-15 JUST RIPS THE BODY
APART.
COULD NOT IDENTIFY, COULD NOT
IDENTIFY THE BODY.
A 20-YEAR-OLD KID CAN WALK IN
AND BUY ONE?
DNA TO SAY THAT'S MY BABY.
WHAT THE HELL IS THE MATTER WITH
US?
I'M NOT JOKING.
THINK ABOUT IT.
WHAT ARE WE DOING?
AND BY THE WAY, HOW MANY -- MY
DAD USED TO LOVE TO HUNT IN THE
POCONOS WHEN WE LIVED IN
SCRANTON.
HOW MANY DEER OR BEAR ARE
WEARING KEVLAR VESTS?
HUH?
NOT A JOKE.
DO YOU REALIZE THE BULLET OUT OF
AN AR-15 TRAVELS FIVE TIMES AS
RAPIDLY AS A BULLET SHOT OUT OF
ANY OTHER GUN.
FIVE TIMES.
IT'S LIGHTER AND CAN PIERCE
KEVLAR.
IMAGINE BEING A PARENT, NOT JUST
LOSING A CHILD, BUT NOT BEING
ABLE TO PHYSICALLY IDENTIFY THAT
CHILD OR THE ADULT, BECAUSE THEY
HAVE LITERALLY BEEN BLOWN APART.
WE EQUIP OUR SERVICE MEMBERS
WITH THE MOST LETHAL WEAPONS ON
EARTH, TO PROTECT ALL OF US.
PROTECT AMERICANS.
BUT WE REQUIRE THEM TO RECEIVE
SIGNIFICANT TRAINING, EXTENSIVE
BACKGROUND CHECKS, MENTAL HEALTH
ASSESSMENTS, THEY HAVE TO LEARN
HOW TO LOCK UP AND STORE THEIR
WEAPONS RESPONSIBLY OR THEY GET
KICKED OUT.
BUT WE LET ANY STRANGER, AN
18-YEAR-OLD, WALK IN, A
20-YEAR-OLD, AND BUY AN AR-15.
THAT'S WHY BACK IN 1994, I TOOK
ON THE NRA AND PASSED THE
ASSAULT WEAPONS BAN.
FOR TEN YEARS, MASS SHOOTINGS
WERE DOWN.
TEN YEARS IN A ROW SINCE I
PASSED THAT LEGISLATION IN 1994
AS A SENATOR.
BUT IN 2004, REPUBLICANS LET
THAT BAN EXPIRE.
WHAT HAPPENED?
MASS SHOOTINGS IN AMERICA
TRIPLED.
IT'S TIME TO BAN THESE.
IT'S TIME TO BAN THESE WEAPONS.
WE DID IT BEFORE.
WE CAN DO IT AGAIN.
[ APPLAUSE ]
TIME TO HOLD EVERY ELECTED
OFFICIAL'S FEET TO THE FIRE AND
ASK THEM ARE YOU FOR BANNING
ASSAULT WEAPONS, YES OR NO?
ASK THEM.
IF THE ANSWER IS NO, VOTE
AGAINST THEM.
LOOK, I'M PROUD THAT AFTER SEVEN
YEARS, WE FINALLY HAVE A SENATE
CONFIRMED DIRECTOR OF ALCOHOL,
TOBACCO, AND FIREARMS
RESPONSIBLE FOR ANY GUN CRIMES.
FOR SEVEN YEARS, THE OTHER TEAM
WOULD NOT LET US APPOINT ANYONE
TO THAT JOB.
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT JOB, TO
HELP LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT,
FEDERAL LAW ENFORCEMENT.
IDENTIFY THE BALLISTICS.
A WHOLE RANGE OF THINGS.
FOR SEVEN YEARS, WE FINALLY GOT
IT PASSED THIS TIME, BARELY.
SEVEN YEARS BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T
WANT ANYBODY IN THAT JOB.
MY PLAN GIVES THE BUREAU THE
FUNDING TO HIRE MORE AGENTS, TO
STOP GUN TRAFFICKING, AND BY THE
WAY, THERE'S A LOT OF STATES
THAT DON'T ALLOW YOU TO PURCHASE
CERTAIN WEAPONS IN THE STATE.
YOU JUST CROSS THE STATE LINE
AND BUY IT NEXT DOOR.
BRING IT ACROSS THE STATE LINE.
KEEP GUNS -- YOU KNOW WHAT THE
MEXICANS -- MEXICO, WHICH HAS
REAL PROBLEMS, CAUSING US REAL
PROBLEMS, YOU KNOW WHAT THEIR
BIGGEST COMPLAINT IT?
CAN'T WE STOP GUN TRAFFICKING
ACROSS THE SOUTHERN BORDER INTO
MEXICO?
THERE ARE CERTAIN GUN DEALERS
THAT ARE BASICALLY, NOT GUN
DEALERS, THEY'RE WHOLESALERS,
PROVIDING THE WEAPONS TO ANYBODY
WHO HAS THE MONEY.
FOLKS, LOOK, WE CAN HELP LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT, WE CAN SOLVE
MORE GUN CRIMES IF WE HAVE
SOMEONE HEADING UP, WHICH WE
FINALLY DO, THIS ORGANIZATION
THAT'S DESIGNED TO TRACK THIS
KIND OF BEHAVIOR.
FINALLY, MY PLAN INVESTS IN
CRIME PREVENTION PROGRAMS THAT
HELP KEEP YOUNG PEOPLE FROM
GETTING IN TROUBLE IN THE FIRST
PLACE.
UNDER MY PLAN, COMMUNITIES CAN
PROVIDE AFTER SCHOOL AND SUMMER
JOB PROGRAMS.
THEY CAN GET PAID FOR IT.
MORE ACCESS TO MENTAL HEALTH AND
DRUG COUNSELING.
MORE SOCIAL WORKERS AND HOUSING
TO KEEP PEOPLE OFF THE STREETS
INSTEAD OF WHEN THEY GET OUT OF
JAIL, THEY GET $25 AND A BUS
TICKET AND END UP UNDER THE SAME
BRIDGE THAT THEY'RE UNDER
BEFORE.
THIS WILL HELP PREVENT CRIME,
GET YOUNG PEOPLE TO PICK UP
PAYCHECKS INSTEAD OF A PISTOL.
THE SAME TIME, WE NEED TO HELP
PEOPLE GETTING OUT OF PRISON
SUCCESSFULLY RE-ENTER SOCIETY SO
THEY DON'T GET IN TROUBLE AGAIN.
IF YOU SERVED YOUR TIME, YOU
SHOULDN'T BE DEPRIVED OF BEING
ABLE TO -- IF YOU SERVED IT, YOU
SHONT BE DEPRIVED OF BEING ABLE
TO GET A PELL GRANT TO GO TO
SCHOOL.
YOU SHOULD BE ABLE TO GET A
DEGREE.
WHAT'S THE BEST THING YOU CAN
DO?
MAKE THEM PRODUCTIVE.
THEY SHOULD GET ACCESS TO GOOD
JOBS WHERE THEY CAN EARN A
DECENT LIVING.
ALL OF THESE STEPS WILL PREVENT
CRIME, NOT INCREASE IT.
LET ME CLOSE WITH THIS.
A SAFER AMERICA REQUIRES ALL OF
US TO UPHOLD THE RULE OF LAW.
NOT THE RULE OF ANY ONE PARTY OR
ANY ONE PERSON.
LET'S BE CLEAR.
YOU HEAR SOME OF MY FRIENDS ON
THE OTHER TEAM TALKING ABOUT
POLITICAL VIOLENCE AND HOW IT'S
NECESSARY.
THINK ABOUT THIS NOW.
DID ANY OF YOU THINK, EVEN IF
YOU'RE AS OLD AS I AM, YOU WOULD
BE IN AN ELECTION WHERE THEY
TALK ABOUT WHERE IT'S
APPROPRIATE TO USE FORCE,
POLITICAL VIOLENCE IN AMERICA?
IT'S NEVER APPROPRIATE.
NEVER, PERIOD.
NEVER, NEVER, NEVER.
NO ONE SHOULD BE ENCOURAGED TO
USE POLITICAL VIOLENCE.
NONE WHATSOEVER.
AND LOOK, YOU KNOW, IF WE'RE IN
A SITUATION WHERE TO THIS DAY
THE MAGA REPUBLICANS IN CONGRESS
DEFEND THE MOB THAT STORMED THE
CAPITOL ON JANUARY 6th.
DEFEND THEM.
YOU ALL SAW IT.
I DON'T CARE HOW FRUSTRATED YOU
ARE.
WHEN I SHOWED UP, ONE OF THE
THINGS I LEARNED AS PRESIDENT,
EVEN THOUGH I HAD BEEN VICE
PRESIDENT FOR EIGHT YEARS AND
DONE A GREAT DEAL ON FOREIGN
POLICY FOR THE ADMINISTRATION, I
SHOWED UP AT A MEETING OF THE
MAJOR DEMOCRACIES CALLED THE G-7
AND I SAT DOWN.
IT WAS IN ENGLAND.
I SAT DOWN FOR THE THREE-DAY
CONFERENCE AND I SAID, AMERICA
IS BACK.
AND MACRON, THE PRESIDENT OF
FRANCE, TURNED TO ME AND SAID,
FOR HOW LONG?
AND WE HAD A DISCUSSION.
JUST FOR HOW LONG?
AND ONE OF THEM SAID TO ME,
IMAGINE, JOE, IF YOU TURN ON THE
TELEVISION IN WASHINGTON, D.C.
AND SAW A MOB OF 1,000 PEOPLE
STORMING DOWN THE HALLWAYS OF
THE PARLIAMENT, BREAKING DOWN
THE DOORS, TRYING TO OVERTURN AN
OUTCOME OF AN ELECTION AND
KILLING SEVERAL POLICE OFFICERS
IN THE MEANTIME, IMAGINE.
IMAGINE WHAT YOU WOULD THINK.
THINK ABOUT WHAT THE WORLD SAW.
NOT WHAT WE SAW, WHAT THE WORLD
SAW.
DID YOU EVER THINK THE UNITED
STATES, IT WOULD HAPPEN?
WHAT I FIND EVEN MORE INCREDIBLE
IS THE DEFENSE OF IT.
COPS ATTACKED AND ASSAULTED,
SPEARED WITH FLAG POLES.
SPRAYED WITH MACE, STOMPED ON,
DRAGGED, BRUTALIZED.
POLICE LOST THEIR LIVES AS A
RESULT OF THAT DAY.
POLICE LOST THEIR LIVES.
ONE OF THE OFFICERS SAID IT WAS
WORSE THAN ANYTHING HE HAD
EXPERIENCED IN WAR IN IRAQ.
SO LET ME SAY THIS TO MY MAGA
REPUBLICAN FRIENDS IN CONGRESS.
DON'T TELL ME YOU SUPPORT LAW
ENFORCEMENT IF YOU WON'T CONDEMN
WHAT HAPPENED ON THE 6th.
DON'T TELL ME.
CAN'T DO IT.
FOR GOD'S SAKE, WHOSE SIDE ARE
YOU ON?
WHOSE SIDE ARE YOU ON?
LOOK.
YOU'RE ON THE SIDE OF THE MOB OR
THE SIDE OF THE POLICE.
YOU CAN'T BE PRO-LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND PRO-INSURRECTION.
YOU CAN'T BE A PARTY OF LAW AND
ORDER AND CALL THE PEOPLE WHO
ATTACK THE POLICE ON JANUARY 6th
PATRIOTS.
YOU CAN'T DO IT.
WHAT ARE WE TEACHING OUR
CHILDREN?
IT'S JUST THAT SIMPLE.
NOW IT'S SICKENING.
TO SEE THE NEW ATTACKS ON THE
FBI.
THREATENING THE LIVES OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENTS AND THEIR
FAMILIES FOR SIMPLY CARRYING OUT
THE LAW AND DOING THEIR JOB.
LOOK, I WANT TO SAY THIS CLEAR
AS I CAN.
THERE'S NO PLACE IN THIS
COUNTRY, NO PLACE, FOR
ENDANGERING THE LIVES OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
NO PLACE.
NONE, NEVER, PERIOD.
I'M OPPOSED TO DEFUNDING THE
POLICE.
I'M ALSO OPPOSED TO DEFUNDING
THE FBI.
LOOK.
THERE'S NO GREATER
RESPONSIBILITY FOR GOVERNMENT
THAN INSURING THE SAFETY OF OUR
PEOPLE.
EVERY PARENT SHOULD BE ABLE TO
KNOW WHEN A KID LEAVES HOME TO
GO TO SCHOOL OR JUST WALK THE
STREET, THEY'RE GOING TO COME
HOME SAFELY.
WE CAN DO THIS.
WE HAVE TO DO THIS.
WE JUST NEED TO REMEMBER WHO WE
ARE.
WE ARE THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA.
WHEN WE ARE UNITED, THERE IS NOT
A SINGLE THING WE CANNOT DO.
NOT A SINGLE THING.
I MEAN IT.
SO FOLKS, LET'S REMEMBER WHO IN
GOD'S NAME WE ARE.
I REALLY MEAN IT, WHAT OUR
VALUES ARE.
WHAT WE BELIEVE.
WE THE PEOPLE.
THAT'S HOW OUR CONSTITUTION
STARTS, THE DECLARATION, WE THE
PEOPLE.
IT'S WHO WE ARE.
AND BY THE WAY, NO ONE EXPECTS
POLITICS TO BE PATTY CAKE.
IT SOMETIMES GETS MEAN AS HELL,
BUT THE IDEA YOU TURN ON A
TELEVISION AND SEE SENIOR
SENATORS AND CONGRESSMEN SAYING
IF SUCH AND SUCH HAPPENS, THERE
WILL BE BLOOD IN THE STREET.
WHERE THE HELL ARE WE?
WELL, THAT'S ALL I'M LOOKING
FOR.
AND FOLKS, DO ME A FAVOR.
PRESUMPTUOUS OF ME TO SAY THAT,
BUT THINK ABOUT DOING ME A
FAVOR.
PLEASE, PLEASE ELECT THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL OF THE SENATE.
ELECT THAT BIG OLD BOY TO BE
GOVERNOR.
AND BY THE WAY, THERE ARE A LOT
OF REALLY, AND I MEAN THIS, I'M
NOT BE SOLICITOUS.
REMEMBER THE CRITICISM OF BIDEN
WHEN I WAS RUNNING.
BIDEN IS TOO BIPARTISAN.
BIDEN HAS TOO MANY REPUBLICAN
FRIENDS.
THERE'S A LOT OF REPUBLICANS I
HAVE WORKED WITH IN ALL THE
YEARS IN THE SENATE.
I GOT A LOT DONE.
WE RESPECTED EACH OTHER.
WHEN WE DISAGREED, WE DISAGREED
ON PRINCIPLE AND THEN HAD LUNCH
TOGETHER.
NOT A JOKE.
WHAT IN GOD'S NAME HAS HAPPENED
TO THAT IN THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA?
SO FOLKS, LET'S BRING IT BACK.
WE C